wir wissen die großartige unsere
soldatinnen soldaten ausgebildet sind
ich durfte selbst mit dabei sein
im auslandseinsatz hochwasser und jetzt
ging eine pandemie schnell korrekt
freundlich menschlich wir brauchen euch
das bundesheer springt immer ein wenn
der hut brennt sind die menschen hinter
dem bundesheer die uns zur seite stehen
beim schneechaos beim hochwasser und
sogar jetzt beim corona tests es ist mir
ein bedürfnis ein großes dankeschön zu
sagen für eure hilfe
[Musik]
dankeschön
ich war drei jahre lang beim herr
sportzentrum und ich habe mit der
unterstützung davon zwei noch solche
sterne gewonnen und fünf
weltmeisterschaften
ich weiß wie gut das bundesheer
organisiert ist und ich glaube an das
bundesheer für die durchführung von den
massen test also die schäden von corona
sind so immens und nachhaltig dass ich
das nicht möchte und für meine kinder
auch nicht deswegen gehe ich dessen und
auch impfen wir müssen uns testen lassen
um ihr sind vor uns da
vielen dank dann kann die damen und
herren soldatinnen soldatinnen wir
brauchen euch um die schalldichte damals
dass er weiter so toll für dieses
anderen arbeitet
[Musik]